vertikalen akzent setzte zu den
originalen nicht jeder künstler sucht
die einsamkeit unter den augen der
öffentlichkeit messen sich im berner
oberland jedes jahr internationale
künstler teams nämlich beim land out
festival in grindelwald
[Musik]
sie knüpfen weben flechten und drapieren
eine woche lang holz gras moos als stein
zu naturkost floristen und landarzt
rückkehrer aus der ganzen welt 100
prozent biologisch abbaubar soll sie
seien von der natur genommen und ihr in
neuer form zurück gegeben frische zweige
schneidet hier niemand das ist verpönt
nebel drähte oder schrauben anbringen
verboten nur zum werkzeug greift der
eine oder andere wenn es nicht anders
geht
die norwegen kommt seit vielen jahren
ins berner oberland für die beiden
estland machen die natürlichste sache
der welt
ich denke ich früher in den ganz alten
zeiten da war das völlig normal dass
menschen etwas schönes machten aus ihrem
haus oder im garten
darum ist diese arbeit in gewisser weise
etwas sehr ursprüngliches die beiden
werken an eine art gehege aus
schwemmholz abstrakt aber mit botschaft
unser konzept zielt auf die idee eines
zauns denn das problem von europa
heutzutage ist ein problem der zäune wer
baut die zäune wer baut die mauern der
dachverein wer nicht
unweit davon team russland im
entscheidenden moment ihr objekt wird
gehängt einen titel trägt es keinen das
ist konzept
die menschen sollen mit dem herzen
schauen
jeder soll selber entscheiden was er von
unserer kunst hält vielleicht ist jetzt
ein konto für insekten wohl ein nest für
kleine vögel
es kommt auf die betrachter an was folgt
und ganz hinten im tal das weitgereiste
team aus singapur erschlägt den letzten
block 1
wir sind sehr glücklich über all dieses
material das man in den schweizer bergen
findet in singapur haben wir sowas nicht
sich in die natur einmischen spontan und
kreativ für den floristen aus dem eher
sterilen stadtstaat erquickend lässt
sich nicht klar
man schaut und gestaltet es geht um
spontane inspiration vor ort auch die
einheimischen mischen mit die
grindelwald nachbauen an einem gebilde
namens architekt ihr land art verzaubert
dann wenn sie sich behutsam und doch
überraschend in ihrer umgebung einfügt
und dort so lange bleibt bis die natur
sie sich wieder einverleibt
nur als foto festgehalten für die
ewigkeit
[Musik]
doch einmal wird sie offiziell gefeiert
an der gut besuchten vernissage festival
gründer peter heß ist zufrieden das
interesse an land art ist in den letzten
20 jahren nicht gesunken
im gegenteil wie sie in den noten groß
wenn man danke was sind das was in einer
stadt den möglich ist beweist dabei um
wirklich ruft bautista popstars das lied
wieder musste musiker ist selber machen
und davon konsumieren
und während die natur kunstfertig ganz
im fokus steht bleiben abseits vom
rummel die wahren meister unendlich dran
[Musik]